i can do this and it can sound exactly
like jeff goldblum are you ready for
this uncanny
my life it finds a way
he got everything he got everything in
yeah it's like listening into a mirror
my goal is to get through all of them
all right i'm going to be pithy i want
to get through all this material i dig
it if you weren't an actor what would
you be doing
i'd be a jazz pianist
i'd be a groomer a a a groomer
yeah i i'd like to do something there
wow i'd like to clip that's what i'd be
whoa yeah you would be a great teacher
of course you'd be i'd like to be in
your class yeah yeah i love the
classroom and i think you'd be a great
teacher and i'd like to be your teaching
assistant
that's great that's great
there we go
what's your go-to karaoke song
you what are you saying you sing
everything well i sing nothing well your
song would be
um why do birds suddenly appear
every time you are near
just like you becky they longed to be
close to him that would be your song
mine
i don't know uh yours would be are you
lonesome
tonight
[Music]
any of the elvis songs
what is your craziest fan story i used
to have this apartment that was very
very hot and i had three fans set up
right next to my bed
and in the middle of the night there
were these moths that flew in behind the
fan and got sucked into the fan
chopped up into bits of moth guts and
spit out all over my face
i was like
what is going on with these fans
spitting moth guts in my mouth because i
sleep with my mouth open
sorry it took many turns that
played upon my
two sensitive innards um
uh me
fans well of course i i like a fan like
like that yeah
uh you know people have associated me
with that fan for years but the fan i
think that you're talking about oh i
don't know
fun crazy there's fun crazy right people
get tattoos of us on their bodies yeah
so that's kind of crazy yeah you know
chris can you give your best impression
of jeff's life finds away lyme
uh this i can do this and it can sound
exactly like jeff goldblum are you ready
for this uncanny
my life it finds a way
he got everything he got everything in
yeah my timbre everything i know it's
weird probably weird for you to hear me
do that it's very weird it's like
listening into a mirror
if you had to pick an alter ego name
what would it be
alter ego names yeah so like sasha
fierce is beyonce oh
oh that's already taken
sasha fierce is taken
i'd be uh
tasha fierce
sasha's taller
sister
tasha fierce that's good
[Laughter]
um yeah that's very good i would be i
would be um well the name of our band
actually is um my band is the mildred
schnitzer orchestra so i might be
mildred mildred schnitzer if the
jurassic world cast formed a band who
would be the lead and what would be your
name
jeff goldblum would absolutely be the
lead
i would play tambo
chris would be the lead absolutely and
the name of the the group would be uh
chris pratt and the pretenders
oh
thank you
that name is so good i'll have to go
with it i mean i didn't think there was
any chance that i would be the lead in
this group but it's tough to it's tough
to top the pretenders what is your
favorite thing about each other
well
jeff is an absolute original
there's no one on the planet like him
and i know that that can be said about
everyone but it's not so true for
everyone there is no one like him he's
an encyclopedic knowledge of film of
every actor of every line that's ever
been spoken on screen and being around
him is like it's like
it's well it's like hanging out with
jeff goldblum
and
no hyperbole it's it's the best time
you'll ever have well chris you know
everybody knows it but let me get in
line to also say that he's
hilariously funny
he's
fiercely intelligent
he's kind and sweet and compassionate
he's generous
he's very beautiful obviously
his rippling muscles
i would
name a dessert after
a
raspberry ripple i would call it
and i would order it each night
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about this is
the best person in the world
i love you so much
do you think you've got the most
dedicated fan base
feels that way yeah yeah the star trek
fans might have something to say about
that
and marvel as well of course
yeah well